but out of the salmon Aaron you work
together and you're also married I work
with my husband closely choose my
manager how does that work like when
you're directing him though that's a
different kind of thing yeah I want to
hear what that's about that moment of
silence I mean because we because we met
that way and we already had that
shorthand in that language and so we
step back on set and it it just
continued in that way really yeah I'm
actually gonna get into it
awesome question I can't wait to ask
because I always my husband I have this
conversation all the time with like
actors there's a love scene and you're
like watching your man yeah have a love
scene like I am like I'm like wow that
would be really hard
well firstly we wrote it and you know
you write it in a way which is fairly
you know you're focusing on the scene
and how it's gonna play out and then
you're on set and a DES is an amazing
actress and and the two of them and I'm
composing the scene and I'm looking at
it and and we're working on it and we're
shooting it over for five hours and it's
it's really a beautiful scene and
incredibly intimate and you probably
just get in the zone
you get in you get in the zone and then
there was just one moment where I turned
to my assistant director and I said
really you had to schedule this on
Valentine's Day
[Laughter]
oh my gosh I said I know I'm
professional and I'm a director but I am
a human being
like this all wound wear damn let's hope
he's a really good actor well no but
that's gotta be that's gotta be awkward
for you though hearing like because you
are a good actor so you want to like be
a good actor but at the same time you're
like I ain't enjoyed this too convincing
I don't know so I've drawn between the
city you think at your own back though I
mean the next morning she have me and
Giovanni butt naked in the shower
and decided to go for a wide shot I love
it I look I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this